[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à ma première année universitaire
j'apprends une nouvelle qui va changer
en partie notre histoire
en effet john aux mecs dans l'eau sera
remplacé sur la figure du dollar par une
femme pour n'importe quelle femme une
afro canadienne qui s'appelle viola
desmond et je dois vous avouer j'étais
très excité mais je n'avais aucune idée
de qui était cette femme et j'ai donc
voulu faire mes recherches
là on apprendre ce personnage elle
permet de favoriser l'évolution entre
les citoyens et les citoyennes
bon je dois vous avouer que quand mes
amis m'ont dit camille il va voir une
femme noire le biais de dollars géré
bien voulu avant de michelle obama mais
elle n'est pas vraiment d'ici vivait là
des semaines si une femme inspirante et
pour ceux et celles qui ne connaissent
pas son histoire elle est née en 1914 à
halifax dans la province de
nouvelle-ecosse et décède en 1965 à new
york
madame des small et avant tout une femme
d'affaires et une mentor pour les jeunes
femmes noires à l'entremise de son école
la culture de la beauté les femmes qui
souhaitaient faire carrière se lancer en
affaires et madame des semaines vendait
des produits pour les cheveux
particulièrement chez les afro
canadienne sa vie va changer
le 8 décembre 1946 lorsqu'elle décide de
se rendre à une réunion d'affaires sa
voiture tombe en talent et en attendant
les réparations et décide d'aller au
ciné mort aux lèvres rendu à la
billetterie elle souhaite s'acheter un
billet du parterre mais la caissière lui
répond je ne peux pas donner un biais du
partage pour les personnes comme vous en
d'autres termes les avoue canadiens et
canadiennes n'avaient pas accès à cette
section met toutefois et le voulu s'y
asseoir car était petite femme menue
entier est bien respectée au sein de sa
communauté
quelques heures plus tard un agent de la
sécurité veulent escorter ils veulent
amener une nuit en prison
il est accusé d'avoir fraudé le
gouvernement et se fait imposer une
amende de 26 dollars
mais il décide de se battre contre cela
le lendemain madame des semaines décide
de porter plainte en vain le gérant et
l'agent de sécurité
c'est une nouvelle qui porte ce à
travers tout le pays ce qui est
particulièrement intéressant c'est que
c'est là
première femme noire qui a soulevé la
question de la ségrégation raciale et de
la situation des afro canadiens malgré
une bataille acharnée elle perd son
combat elle décide de se rendre à la
cour suprême mais les délais sont
dépassés et l'accusation demeure après
cet épisode
madame d'espagne s'installe à montréal
et un mille séjour à new york
par contre sa soeur wendy dobson décide
d'écrire le livre ma soeur dawn en
anglais
six tueurs de sol en 2010 dans la même
année
le lieutenant gouverneur général de la
nouvelle-écosse vous présenter des
excuses auprès d'un management pour
cette erreur judiciaire et les connu à
part dans toute la province et elle sera
connue dans tout le pays
grâce à ce billet de 10 dollars c'est
une histoire pas seulement remarquable
et qui mérite d'être connue dans notre
jeunesse on l'appelle même la rosa
portes du canada c'est qu'il n'a pas
voulu céder sa place dans un autre bus
lors de la ségrégation raciale des états
unis et le ministre des finances du
canada choisit des semaines par son
courage sa dignité sa détermination et
sa force mission souviens bien
g desmond vit dans une époque ok les
tensions raciales sont plus difficiles
et auquel il y a
les noirs sont considérés de seconde
classe
maintenant je vais être franche avec
vous et on se comprend c'est pas facile
de revoir ces périodes et ça peut causer
à une forme de malaise car ce sont des
épisodes dans notre histoire qui ne sont
pas beaucoup raconté mais c'est
important de ne pas les oublier
parce que depuis plusieurs années le
canada fait face à plusieurs
revendications que ça soit par des
groupes minoritaires
que ça soit par la religion
l'orientation sexuelle les origines et
j'en passe et peut-être on comprend pas
à 100% ce que ces personnes revendiquent
où vivent mes connaître le contexte
historique va permettre de comprendre la
situation actuelle et à mener vers des
solutions pour une meilleure inclusion
et une meilleure communication et je
vous explique pourquoi
en 2017 la chercheuse indépendante
montréalaise robin maintenant de publier
le livre pour racing
drive qu'on appelle en français noirs
sous surveillance
elle explique l'histoire des noirs de l
esclavage jusqu'à aujourd'hui elle tente
avant tout d'exposer les inégalités dans
les institutions canadiennes et en
d'autres termes surtout des squelettes
de notre plaque or on a beaucoup entendu
parler d injustice si nos voisins les
américains mais si cette réalité elle
passe un peu sur adore et c'est pour ça
que site
ce livre est important l'empiré
britannique va abolir esclavage en 1834
mais par la suite il y avait plusieurs
pratiques qui tentait de séparer les
communautés blanches et les communautés
noires que les historiens vont appeler
la loi du mco du canada du nom des lois
ségrégationnistes aux états unis
cependant les personnes noires ont
souvent une étiquette comme étant des
personnes tunnel et dangereuse même
trente ans plus tard le premier ministre
john holmes et d'andres vos conseillers
aux communautés blanches de s'éloigner
d'eux comme il dit ces prédateurs et en
d'autres mots la couleur de la peau
noire a été relié quelque chose de
négatif est criminel et c'est une image
qui a perduré durant plusieurs années
voici une des parties que mobiles
maintenant explique dans son livre et
qu'il n'est pas évident à lire mes mails
regardons l'évolution que nous avons
devant nous regarder la personne qui est
à côté de vous où les gens qui sont
auprès de vous on tente avant une
meilleure évolution une meilleure
communication et je suis très heureuse
d'être devant vous ce soir
toute ma vie j'ai été entouré d'une
bonne famille issue de l'adoption
internationale et j'ai eu la chance
d'avoir des expériences inoubliables
mais peut arriver des situations
irritant je me souviendrai toujours la
fois où je suis allé au départ avec mes
amis pour aller acheter des friandises
lorsque nous sommes allés à la caisse et
mon ami a déposé l'argent
la caissière rhodia son collègue vite se
reprendre le 20 pourquoi qu'elles le
volent et je voulais me retourner
derrière il n'y avait personne d'autre
voilà on pensait que j'avais volé
l'argent et ne savais pas que c'était
mon ami qui était devant moi dans la
même année
après une soirée chez des amis
je suis retourné chez moi à pied une
voiture est passée à baisser sa fenêtre
et me demander où tu vois comme ça et je
leur ai répondu que je retournais chez
moi et je devais leur répondre ou que
j'habitais et ils m'ont dit c'est
impossible que tu habites l'heure qui
vous de montrer des cartes
c'était une voiture de police ce ne sont
pas des situations qui m'arrive souvent
mais quand ils arrivent et sont
irritantes et j'ai eu des situations et
qui me sont déjà arrivés et duquel mes
collègues m'ont rapporté se faire suivre
dans un magasin et se faire demander
sont reçus avant de partir se faire
demander ces cartes d'identité par la
police plusieurs fois dans la journée se
faire demander de payer son repas dans
un restaurant avant même de le recevoir
et peut-être que ce sont des situations
anormales
la majorité des concitoyens mais chez
les personnes noires et même autochtone
c'est une solution des situations qui
peuvent nous arriver il malgré tout la
chance et le privilège que j'ai eu dans
ma vie la couleur de la peau peut
déranger émettant qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour amener vers une meilleure inclusion
une meilleure communication
c'est ce que mes collègues ont souvent
posé et m'ont demandé durant toutes ces
années
et voici ce que je leur réponds il faut
commencer par une vision optimiste et
positive
et pour cela il faut une représentation
équitable et tout peut commencer par s
dollars
qu'est-ce que viala des spl peut nous
amener à travers notre société elle nous
permet de sortir des squelettes de notre
plaque or elle permet de rejoindre les
citoyens de tous les horizons
aujourd'hui on a entrouvert une page qui
n'était pas facile mais qui est
importante parce que viola desmond c'est
votre histoire
si notre histoire et vous faire la liste
il faut continuer la lecture de celle ci
parce que comme dit la politicienne les
limites cloud
il faut connaître le passé pour
comprendre le présent et faire face à
l'avenir
parce qu'en fait avant tout que nos
prochaines générations de se sentir et
respecté comme les canadiens canadiens
et québécois et québécoises viola des
semaines et un début le reste nous
appartient merci
[Applaudissements]